firstly is my father and he is best
well-known as a martial artist
interaction film star as I'm sure most
of you know he died when I was 4 years
old but I have a really deep memory of
him I don't have those long form storied
memories that you do when you're older
but the memory that I do have is of the
feeling of him I remember his energy his
presence his love the safety of it the
power of it the radiance of it and to me
that memory is very deep and personal
and it is the memory of the quality of
his essential nature what a lot of
people don't know about my father is
that he was also a philosopher he had a
very ever-evolving philosophy that he
lived and it is that distinction that he
lived his philosophy and didn't just
espouse his philosophy that made him the
force of nature that he was and still
engages us today his wisdom has salvaged
me many times in my life when my brother
died when my heart's been broken
whenever I have faced a challenge to my
mind my body or my spirit the way that
he expressed himself has lifted me up
and so I come to you today not as a
researcher or an educator or a guru or
even a life coach but as a student of
Bruce Lee as his daughter and also as a
student of my own life so my big burning
question that I want you all to consider
today is how are you let me elaborate
whenever anyone would ask my mom what my
father was like
she would say how he was in front of the
camera how you saw him in his films how
you saw him in his interviews was in
fact exactly how he was there were not
multiple Bruce Lee's there was not
public Bruce Lee in private Bruce Lee or
teacher Bruce Lee and actor Bruce Lee
and family man Bruce Lee there was just
one unified total Bruce Lee and that
Bruce Lee at a very deep philosophical
life practice called self-actualization
you've probably heard that term before
it's also known as how to be yourself in
the best way possible and that Bruce Lee
said this when I look around I always
learn something and that is to be always
yourself and to express yourself and
have faith in yourself don't go out and
find a successful personality and
duplicate it but rather start from the
very root of your being which is how can
I be me many of us have done some
soul-searching or at least some
incessant thinking and worrying about
things like our purpose our passion our
impacts our values and our reason for
being and that is sometimes considered
sort of our why why am I here why this
life why what am I meant to be doing if
we can grab a little piece of that
information it can help to ground us and
root us and it can also point us in a
direction and typically what it points
us to is our what what we manifest in
the world what we have so our job our
home our hobbies and the like but
there's this little space in between the
why and the what that often doesn't get
our full attention and that is our how
how we get there and the quality of that
doing and I want to offer that this is
actually the most important part of the
equation when it comes to our personal
growth our sense of wholeness
and even the long-term impact that we
make how is the action that bridges the
gap from the internal to the external
and bridging the gap is a very important
concept for a martial artists like my
father it's how you get from point A to
point B it's how you get from here to
your target under the most vital of
circumstances and so it makes all the
difference do you get there as an
amateur are you sloppy are you a wild
chaotic sometimes you get lucky
sometimes you're not lucky or are you a
warrior very confident are you focused
are you skilled are you intuitive are
you expressive creative aware so I want
to talk to you today about your how in
your life so we do a little bit of we
spend a little time an existential
crisis over why am I here what am I
meant to be doing and we put a ton of
effort into our what our job our career
our partner that we have the hobbies we
pursue but I want us to consider that
our how is the expression of our why in
every what whether we're aware of it or
not and so let's take an example let's
say that I have a value of kindness I'm
all about kindness
I feel really natural being kind I want
to see more kindness in the world is
that kindness is that value in the
result or is it in the doing are you
trying to be kind when it's hard to be
kind can you do something you don't want
to do kindly like fire someone can you
leave a relationship with kindness
if kindness is the value then are you
trying to express it in the whole
spectrum of your doing where
and trying to do that or are you just
doing it when it's easy so I want us to
think about that for a moment and
consider you know if we come home and
we're kind and generous and loving with
our kids but then we go to work and we
are dismissive and rude to our assistant
and we treat them like a subhuman then
there is a fragmentation in the
beingness of our value and so I want us
to consider that how we are in our lives
is in fact how we are meaning if I am
the kind of person that walks down the
street and smiles at people and says hi
as I walk past them on the sidewalk then
that is how I am but if I'm also the
kind of person who makes fun of my
brother every chance that I get behind
his back that is also the kind of person
that I am and ultimately how we are
makes up the totality of the picture of
who we are and so I want to talk about
how do we unite these pieces with we
have any fragmentation I want to
understand how we embody ourselves as
our one and only self how do we
actualize the whole self
my father said all goals apart from the
means are an illusion there will never
be means to ends only means and I am
means I am what I started with and when
it is over I will be all that is left so
you can employ a systematic approach to
training and practicing but you can't
employ a systematic approach to actually
living because life is a process not a
goal it is a means and not an end so to
obtain enlightenment and I'm gonna say
self actualize to be self actualized or
to obtain wholeness emphasis should fall
not on the cultivation of the particular
departments all of our what
which then merges into the totality of
who we are as a total human being but
rather on the total human being that
then enters into and unites those
particular departments you are you're
how you if you have some consciousness
and you want to bring some practice if
you want to step into that warrior space
around your how how you express in every
aspect of your life then you get to be
the artist of that expression you get to
step into that and claim it and exercise
it and bring that beingness through your
doing this into your havingness and
there you will find the most profound of
your growth you will find a sense of
wholeness and ultimately you will leave
a lasting impact on your environment my
father was his how he applied the
execution of who he was to every aspect
of his life he was way more than that
kung-fu guy from the 70s he was someone
who worked very hard at actualizing his
inner self and expressing it out into
the world and that laid the foundation
for what continues to inspire us engage
us excite us and attract us to him he
was the embodied example of living fully
he said I am means and their only means
so I'm going to ask you one more time
thank you for listening and please
consider for you across the spectrum of
your doing how are you thank you
[Applause]